thanks to Babel a language learning app
or sponsoring this episode if you're
interested in growing your language
skills microcosmos viewers get up to 60
off with a 20-day money-back guarantee
when you sign up using our Link in the
description
[Music]
you may not want to think about it this
way but your mouth is really just one
giant wet cave for microbes sure it's
also a mouth which means that it's part
of a body that does all the mouth things
that the body needs it to do it bites
and digests and tastes but from the
perspective of bacteria like these your
mouth is not a tool it's a home it's a
place that provides shelter and food but
it is also a place that can pose many
threats and the intervalid between our
mouths and the microbes that take up
residents within them ends up inevitably
affecting our own health we'll start
this episode today with a similar
disclaimer to the one we made when we
talked about dust mites in your home
while watching this video you may find
yourselves suddenly gripped by a desire
to clean only this time instead of
seeking out a broom to flush the dust
mites out of your home you might find
yourself reaching for a toothbrush so it
is with that in mind time that we need
to extend a big thank you to Ella a
friend of our master of microscopes Ella
kindly ate a lot of sugary food and
skipped brushing her teeth for two days
to make this video possible when Ella
texted James that quote my mouth is
totally gross and perfect for sampling
the result was this Tartar and plaque
scraped off her gums and the spaces
between her teeth within these samples
you can see dense populations of
bacteria some of which move around quite
a bit like the corkscrew-shaped Spyro
Keats here as is so often the case the
microscopist Anthony Von lievenhoek got
there long before we did in 1677 he
published a paper documenting the little
animalcules he observed under the
microscope among his many illustrations
and depictions is a set of drawings
depicting the bacteria that came from
his own mouth
[Music]
in 1889 a dentist named Willoughby
Dayton Miller published the book die
microorganisms
which was translated and published a
year later under the English title the
microorganisms of the human mouth the
local and general diseases which are
caused by them in the first chapter he
wrote it has been established beyond all
question that myriads of microorganisms
are constantly present in the human
mouth and that these under favorable
circumstances are capable of manifesting
an action of the utmost significance
upon the local as well as the General
Health of the patient
this statement would be the foundation
of a major shift in our understanding of
tooth decay at the time there was a
theory that tooth decay was caused by
some kind of wiggling worm that needed
to be driven out of our mouths but
Miller developed an alternative
explanation called chemoparasitic Theory
where the bacteria in our mouths ferment
sugars but in the process release acids
which then cause our teeth to Decay and
humans had been cleaning their teeth for
Millennia including with ancient tools
like porcupine quills but the chemo
parasitic Theory gave a more specific
and accurate framework to think about
how we clean our teeth and it would
shape much of how we approached dental
disease in the 20th century including
brushing your teeth flossing and the
addition of fluoride to toothpaste but
while Miller's work helped us uncover
the idea of microbes as a mass
interacting with our teeth it turns out
that understanding the specific roles of
individual microbes within that mass is
much more complicated to understand how
complicated we only need to look at two
of the protists we've found on Ella's
teeth the first is trichomonas 10x the
gourd shaped creature swimming here
trichomonas 10x likes to take up
residence in the teeth gums tongue and
saliva and it is associated with several
diseases in the body but it's not clear
if it's involved at all in periodontal
disease which you can think of as
diseases that involve inflammation of
the gums scientists have been finding
trichomonas 10x in samples that come
from patients who have periodontal
diseases since the 1960s but that is not
the same as finding out that the microbe
itself is causing disease
and then there's the blob-shaped
entamoeba gingivallis which was the
first amoeba found inside of humans it
has a name that you might immediately
associate with gingivitis and for good
reason this protist is found in high
numbers in people with periodontitis but
again that doesn't necessarily mean this
protist actually causes the disease it
might be that these protists are
involved in the disease or it might be
that the changes in the mouth that lead
to periodontitis also make for a
comfortable home from the perspective of
trichomonas 10x and entamoeba gingivalis
the oral microbiome is one of the
largest and most diverse microbiomes in
your body second only to the microbiome
of our guts and every day that we eat
drink brush and loss brings changes to
the environment they live in some of
which are too large for the microbial
communities to weather we started it by
describing your mouth as a big moist
cave for microbes and the comparison
holds up when you think about the
complex and mysterious ecosystems that
live within caves they are enigmatic
creatures that latch onto walls and swim
within the waters that hide themselves
and shape the environment around them
but for the organisms of the cave of
your mouth well
we feed them and we nourish them and
then we destroy them because we have to
never fully knowing what it is that we
have washed down the sink
[Music]
foreign
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you again to
Babel for sponsoring this episode of
Journey to the micro Cosmos are you
looking to learn a new language this
year usually trying to learn a new
language requires a lot of time and
commitment making it difficult to
quickly get into conversations well
Babel is a language learning app that
helps you use a new language in real
life situations after only five hours of
practice and it offers lessons in 14
different languages it's the number one
language learning app in the world and
with its short interactive 10-minute
lessons Babel teaches you more than just
vocab words it teaches you about the
culture people history and more
associated with the language you are
learning and Babel offers multiple ways
to learn including podcasts Games videos
and live classes so you can choose
whatever format works best for you as a
microcosmos viewer you'll get sixty
percent off when you sign up using our
link plus battle comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee so you can see
where Babel takes you on your language
learning Journey
I'd like to say a quick thanks to all
the people whose names are on the screen
right now who allow us to keep diving
deeper into the weird places that we can
find microbes on planet Earth that of
course being pretty much everywhere
including right there in your own mouth
if you're interested in helping us be
able to continue making this show you
can check out patreon.com journey to
micro if you'd like to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss you
can check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]